turning boys into men in a politically
correct world that's tonight's angle at
the first annual Obama Foundation's
summit in Chicago former first lady
Michelle Obama assumed the role of
social scientist as she warned women not
to spoil the men in their lives it's
like the problem in the world today is
we we we love our boys and we raise our
girls you know we raised them to be
strong and sometimes we take care not to
hurt men and it's powerful to have
strong men but what does that strength
mean you know does it mean respect does
it mean responsibility does it mean
compassion or are we protecting our men
too much so they feel a little entitled
and a little you know you know a little
self-righteous sometimes it seems that
mrs. Obama was making kind of a veiled
reference to the myriad sexual
harassment allegations that have rocked
Hollywood the business world and media
companies as for her claim that the
world is dangerous for women that's kind
of a bit of an overstatement at least
for women in the United States but
regardless Michelle is right to this
extent women do at times protect their
men too much and enable their abusive
behavior Hillary Clinton comes to mind
who Michelle Obama enthusiastically
supported in the last election but was
girl power really on display when
Hillary attacked Bill's accusers
shamelessly trashing women who alleged
against her husband some of the very
same behavior that has been alleged
against Harvey Weinstein remember the
bimbo eruptions and let's not forget
that it took the Obamas and the Clintons
five days to find the words to condemn
their friend and their campaign bundler
Weinstein and written statements people
who never spoke out before having the
courage to speak out just clearly
demonstrates that this behavior that
he engaged in cannot be tolerated
okay took a while and I'd be more
willing by the way to listen to Michelle
Obama's advice on child-rearing
and the sexes if she had herself not
enabled the ultimate enabler Hillary
Clinton and that's the angle